[Music]
thanks guys i'm here outside the famous
tcl chinese theater in hollywood where
you're about to see some of the craziest
characters you've ever seen not because
they're dressed up in star wars costumes
but because they're waiting in line for
two weeks for a movie they already have
tickets to let's begin what creature did
luke and han use to stay warm in hoth's
frigid temperatures
oh my god
or taunton that's right at what
temperature does water boil
oh uh water boils at uh oh my god name
one member of the star wars galactic
senate massameter yes one member of the
u.s senate the u.s senate
name one member of the star wars
galactic senate bail organa
name one member of the u.s senate
name one member of the star wars
galactic senate queen ontario
true
name one member of the u.s senate
who was the apprentice to darth plagueis
the wise
uh that would have been
uh emperor palpatine correct who was the
vice presidential candidate under mitt
romney
that's embarrassing i do not know that
don't worry about it you don't want to
ask me political questions i don't know
what he's doing to me it seems
involuntary what else are you doing this
week
there's a couple that i'm officiating
their wedding actually guys why did you
choose star wars for this to be your
special day i was gonna have a lot of
star wars stuff in the wedding anyway
yeah i always wanted to walk to vader's
the imperial march and have storm
troopers wait wait you're gonna walk to
the imperial march oh bugger that was
gonna be a surprise well i hope you guys
have an awesome wedding and an even
better honeymoon and help you out here
are two star wars fandango gift cards
for you guys
to take yourself so you can go to the
movies take your eventual kids